hey Kipping him tickets for the live
show are flying off the shelf you ain't
lying gang we just dropped a bunch of
new cities stand up comedy plus we
played a little ayg with the crowd it's
a good good time yeah gang we're coming
to Phoenix Denver Salt Lake City Los
Angeles San Diego Washington D.C
Pittsburgh Buffalo Toronto Pontiac
Michigan then we're going to Chicago
Illinois we're going to Minneapolis
we're going to Madison Milwaukee
Sacramento San Francisco San Jose and
then the boys are coming back to Philly
the chickens are coming home to Rose
Philadelphia Pennsylvania in December
get those tickets we love yous welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
the girl to be classy yeah after just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here with
hoodies and the new edition she's out
scalping a couple of Phillies tickets
okay trying to get a little cash uh-huh
that's all I got this week my co-host is
coming at you from across the table he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he is the king
of the flatbreads the king of the boards
and the prince of the personal pan pizza
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan shut
up have you had one today what a
flatbread yeah no I had a green juice
for breakfast you did look at you yeah
man
uh shout out uh first of all thanks for
listening you got me all flustered I
don't know what's going on
Jesus I know I think it did have a
flatbread I got to be quite a BBQ
flatbread on the brain thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure your rate
if you subscribe on iTunes all video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are over 150 000 babies and
obviously the greatest gosh darn website
of all time
www.patreon.com okay are you garbage you
go over there okay and you get about two
three billion gajillion hours of bonus
content sure over there you got episodes
you get videos you get Road Vlogs you
get the cribs videos the all
everything's on there it's a lot going
on over there on that website I'll tell
you that more than you think and the
second greater website of greatest
website of all time are you garbage.com
because we're about to drop the second
leg of the tour sure and you get all
your tickies over there oh you got merch
too we got a bunch of t-shirts we got
Zippo style lighter sure you can get
your hands on and let me give you a
heads up when the tickets do drop some
of those markets are gonna go very
quickly yes
[Laughter]
we're announcing a [__] ton of dates the
6000 seat theater in Duluth might be a
little tough to fill I'll be paper in
that thing
but it's gonna be fun make sure you
check that out and have a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones the twos crosses the t's
and that's the eyes he's wearing wet
jeans right now
Toby wettest
[__] Mudbud over here came it up for
T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen
everybody what up dudes what up dog my
laundromat was like Penn Station today
I've never seen more than one other
person there were 95 people in there
dryers are all jammed up we gotta get in
here I got wet pants there's no worse
there's no worse feeling as a kid that
would happen you'd get jammed up
sometimes like if I was doing my long or
whatever and I would forget to switch it
and they'd be you know you're going into
did you do your laundry as a child yeah
single mom you did yeah she wasn't doing
it no kidding at a very early age I mean
you got to figure my sister was probably
15 my brother's 13. would they help you
out I'm eight eight yeah you're doing
laundry at eight she hung up on on post
what are you a breaker boy that's crazy
you're doing your own your mom still
does your laundry and she does it well
yeah and you scream at her when she
[__] she better not she doesn't fold
your undies
um there was a uh she got like a piece
of poster board and wrote like this is
how you do colors whites dry this that
that it was I mean it lived there it
lived there until I was through college
geez yes I was like your sister wouldn't
do it for you what no eight years old
you weren't doing laundry at eight were
you no shot I can barely do it now I got
damp pants on yeah it's true dude damn
pants will make you question every
decision you've ever made in your life I
like it they're a little looser plus it
cools you off in the summer time nah
your money gets wet and stuff because
the pockets the pockets are always the
last thing to drive a tough look you
ain't trying to hand it to a cashier for
a packet heaters they're alive they're
eyeballing you nothing worse than a wet
five yikes the ice cream man looking at
you funny where were you with this yeah
it's bam Jesus Christmas yeah and then I
hated it and I felt like I would go to
school with it and everybody would know
you know what I mean I'm like they all
know I got wet pay I'll be checking the
seat to make sure there wasn't like
[__] make sure I wasn't leaving a
mark Kevin got his period
would you make your own lunch no I would
we bought Tim I mean yeah I bought it
was a peanut butter sandwich and a coke
most days a probably a bag full of
Doritos or sourdough nibblers I would do
um did your own laundry yeah man it's
crazy at eight listen fifteen I
understand I wouldn't do it but I get it
but it ate that's a hard-nosed kid I
wonder why you started smoking at seven
dude my mom do you have to think about
where she came she was one of nine in a
two bedroom they grew up in a shoe I get
it they were [__] working sure her
brothers were dropping out of school to
[__] to be like a tin knocker she was
hanging drywall yeah it's like she's
like yeah you fat little bastard I keep
I keep you flush with the [__] with
the peanut butter sandwiches and Elio's
Pizza you can do your own [__]
laundry man would you do it like would
you have a day where you did it no no I
didn't have to do that in the bills no I
mean she did she did my laundry
dude she had a blue it was either kids
or Reebok but a blue box with just past
due bills sure envelopes rip how they
had the accordion thing oh she still
doesn't it yeah yeah that thing was out
you did not ask for like a new pair of
shoes or hey can I get a new skateboard
or anything it was [__] Patty's
checkbook man every single line is I
still would I would have no idea how to
balance how to figure out something like
that that's why you are not in charge of
the book of course they tried to teach
us I think in accounting or something
like that but that was already that was
junior year high school I don't know
what the hell was going on it's like
yeah I put a movie on will you Jesus got
a little seven up going in here you
gotta go to approach your checkbook here
in The Hurt Locker it's a big old suit
on
there's four other guys standing around
he's a psycho dude this guy's nuts that
thing's all jammed up
yeah man no uh I wouldn't she did my
laundry but if I needed something done
if I would you know so she did do your
laundry yeah I mean but not exclusively
it wasn't like Mom I need my laundry
done type thing uh-huh if I needed
something done what about like soccer
uniforms they hide Patty on a rotation
yeah fresh gear and look where it got
you she's still I was a star athlete I
needed a support system
star athlete for a minute you were a
role player at the best
utility guy yeah you came off the bench
pretty well I'll give you that you gave
him a good minute
he's good for eight minutes couple of
fumbles I'll wait till you guys get up
and get ahead about 50 points I don't
come in and wow I'll really come in and
stun them show them how it's done I was
load manager what is it load management
what are you doing as far as uh laundry
detergent are you getting it there using
the powder aren't you no sugar
sugar-free Red Bull
that shirts came to play dog
drives in two seconds it's just in there
vaping I uh I I always buy the little uh
the little bangers they sell a little
bit or whatever that's good yeah that's
good so you did laundry this morning oh
yeah high heat what are you rocking in
the in the dryer ice cold really you go
no heat almost while your shit's not dry
dude [__] no oh no no I do no heat too
oh cold water of course yeah it can't do
hot I can't gamble on it sure you found
that out the hard way fatty what doing
your own laundry oh
I'm a master of it [__] washing your
undies on hot no I'm cold dude I'm
cleaning a Band-Aid down there I'm like
I'm like a baker dude I got that [__]
perfect I [__] pull off pull it out
of the dryer before it starts really
tightening up now some of those Fabrics
they [__] before the buttons get hot
oh man [__] [__] torching your
little your little Pub damn button fly
jeans really Jamie up I thought I had
herpes for a week
it's just a second degree burn
Something's Cooking down you know what I
saw the other day I wanted to ask you
guys
a few of the households in our family
had these and I think it's probably
fleas the ultimate the ultimate trash
like you know how the people had like
the um the pope and John F Kennedy and
Lou Holtz or whatever their pictures the
ultimate track blue Holtz yeah the guy
from CSI head coach of Notre Dame
football national championship 1988. you
have a picture of Lou Holtz in your
house no hmm right Connie but okay fair
enough
um is the mix
of different mob movie actors in one
painting oh like the final supper or
whatever yeah the Last Supper where Tony
Sopranos is Tony Soprano Al Pacino Tom
Sizemore while sitting around playing
cards Tom seism was here hey he's the
plug you know what I mean shout out to
Tom Sizemore come on just watch Heat the
other day
um damn is that good
yeah no he uh those are very trashy and
like it was so funny because when I
first
wanted to decorate my dorm room or my
apartment that was like the coolest
thing for me it was like get a Scarface
poster gets a picture of some hot broad
some TNA or sure you know what I mean it
was like Carmen Electra
I liked her she went a little early for
me I think it was like a little too
early who are you into I mean obviously
Britney Spears was hockey did you have a
Britney Spears poster on your wall yeah
I did we talked about this at my dad's
house yeah uh-huh my mom wouldn't go for
that obviously who was doing a laundry
at your old man's
uh my stepmom or me yeah okay uh well
what age uh uh I guess we're in that
house of probably 10 yeah so my stepmom
were here I would take clothes back and
forth like a [__] I was riding the
rails man looking back that [__] was
depressing a little hobo bag packing a
bag for two nights go over your dad's
house you [__] goldfish and drink
walleyes
steal a heater too uh
keeping your money in a lunch meat bag
[__]
keeping all my all my personal
possessions under my ball sacks no one
can get it
um yeah no I man yeah that was that just
[__] rocked me thinking about packing
a bag little kid packing a [__] bat
or sometimes I wouldn't even have about
just like just bring over like a like a
t-shirt and underwear or whatever man
because I didn't have two wardrobes so
it was like most of the stuff I was
based I was you know I was based out of
my mom's got the whites going it your
dad's the colors going at your mom I was
all over the place that's like a guy in
an affair yeah no for sure yeah I was
switching phone batteries and stuff
flopping switching Sims Matt Damon into
the Departed uh
yeah no that was uh I would take clothes
back and forth if something needed to be
done a hoodie or whatever in junior high
or high school I would I would I would
do it Junior High in high school I was
definitely doing sure for sure I was
doing my own stuff uh not me man
never yeah she didn't want us touching
it he didn't want us down there [__]
that up yeah I think that leads to your
Arrested Development sure for sure she
cuddles you she still does she's got to
cut the goddamn cord nah too late now
what's she gonna be 90 doing your
laundry she just do my laundry you're
70. yes she does we've had arguments
about it if I go home and I have some
stuff but now we got the dry washer and
dryer in the unit so I do it in there
I actually haven't done it in a long
time
hey Kate puts I know you smell like a
[__] hockey bag over here
I can get a little fabric softener
something and I spilled coffee on the
shirt that I wore today so I had to go
to my locker shirt yeah keep that in
there lucky if I keep it up I'll stuff
you in there we got lockers
um
yeah no I would always do it yeah but
then like a lot of times I always I'm
such a bad procrastinator that if I
needed something done I wouldn't do it
and then I'd be like I was very good at
fluffing something up for the day of
course I could do that I could work no
but I mean like I mean this shirt could
be at the bottom of the bottom of the
bottom I remember having a system of
like can I give you my as can I get them
please go ahead no please no no no no no
do go on
please
couple sprays a cologne a wet washcloth
in the dryer yeah that was mine that's
every dirt bag that had to [__] make
a sweaty shirt smell nice so you [__]
chicks don't laugh at you I was every
fat kid's [__] go to a couple of
spritzes of Eternity but not right on it
you had to like just get the molecules
out of the atmosphere maybe go under the
pits oh yeah and also heavy on the dryer
sheets
well not too much because then I'm Gonna
Leave a white residue on it how many
dryer sheets are you supposed to use
because I know what I do stuff I'm in a
tube and Blair weed smoke through them
shout out to it they were great to throw
Denise off the center of me catching
heaters too keep one or two of them in a
car [__]
come in smelling like [__] Sunday
laundry baby
yeah dryer sheets are huge wash your
hand if you had a dryer sheet at 14 you
weren't getting caught with heaters now
they were all right but I do four in the
dryer four dryer sheets
I think that's excessive is it I think
it should be it's more than one it's
probably two two I've done three three
just I don't like I mean you feel that
[__] film the film on it yeah it's
just like and that can't be good for you
no they say it's [__] horrible it's
got forever chemicals written all yeah
that's that's changing your DNA you're
half [__] bounce right now
you know three percent bounce big guy
uh one sheet for small to average size
loads and two sheets that's recommended
for average to large loads so I imagine
your load about eight You're Gonna Wanna
run I just throw a whole box in there
nine sheets for a real fat ass that's
what you want to get in there is he a
real fair pig put about 10 in there are
you watching any button-down boat tarps
get any [__] spare tire covers that
was always a jam up too
the different clothes would dry
differently the hoodie would take
forever the button-down shirts all
wrinkled the jeans are all jammed up I
used to wear and I never had heard the
any adhered to any white colors I mean I
still don't I dropped my stuff off now
they go separate I go what separately
everything around is black or dark gray
so it's not a real emo yeah it's all
going in there together buddy but I
don't take stuff to them sit there right
in your poem book because I I still air
dry stuff as a [__] as a chubster
there's certain shirts or I'm like I'm
not giving these out because if they're
they're not they're coming back petite
coming back they're coming back extra at
the laundromat yeah yeah even at home
I'll wash it and then I air dry I got a
rack you air dry it now when you air
when you do it when you throw the rack
up I have a whole system I got an
oscillating fan I put on my I put on a
table to like blast it are you just
letting it free free ball it I'm just
free balling I don't even have done that
yeah if it seems like you're [__]
building the bridge as as you're
Crossing it type thing ah we're moving
yeah if you're waiting on the
oscillating fan the dry your [__] he's
microwaving his pants yeah
I-45 if the humidity's low man yeah now
that's no good damn Danny over here yeah
turn the jeans inside out dude I don't
that's why you're always looking it
rained a little bit
just like he came out of the Everglades
he caught in a storm everything's a
little dewy were you in the butterfly
cage for 20 minutes dude using a
communal thing uh the I hate I I you
just have to do it you live in New York
it's very rare I mean [__] money
Daddy Warbucks over here has one in his
in his [__] apartment living like the
goddamn King maybe I've maybe used it
ten times in the in the few months so
one of the smaller ones that up in like
the top like stacked yeah yeah but it
ain't small it's nice yeah nice
Whirlpool I think it is one sock at a
time Whirlpool yeah Whirlpool do you
have is it uh is it one of like the
sensing things you put it in and then it
does the math it runs an algorithm like
it doesn't just start they just like my
mom has one
that like say it's like no my mom has
that it's like just [__] start it's
taking 20 minutes to [__] put a CPU
to boot you think you broke it it's like
yeah yeah it's like weighing it it's
figuring it out buddy just get the pizza
stains out of my black t-shirt let's go
I like the old school ones there was one
in the Airbnb I think in Indy where real
old school no digital just love it just
dial then then you pull it that was the
that was the one I had growing up pop it
you had a we had a white like not white
they were like tan yeah off-white
Whirlpool these things [__] he could
send to space great and you would just
go you
crank it like an old rotary phone and
then pull the
baby right at Niagara Falls and yeah it
starts gushing ice cold water out
[__] foam starts going and then
you know you're getting clean clean
drawers and I would keep the you keep
the door open let it pour out to get
some water in there oh yeah then you hit
it with the then you hit it with the
flavor you go in there with the [__]
sauce it's like dropping a bullion cube
in there I think then you drop that
thing down and you hear that in this
that indistinctable cocoon the way it
closes it locks up on you yeah all right
I think the proper way to do it I
remember reading this as a kid
my OCD kicked in I was like I gotta find
out the best way to make the best way to
Better Homes and Gardens
I still am but looking back
I can't picture you on a Sunday with the
owner's manual on the seat
Ma you heard about this spin cycle
you got zucchini bread in the oven
shout out to zucchini bread by the way
um I I think the proper way
it used to be with the liquid detergent
is you fill it completely add the
detergent let that completely sure so
that that becomes completely won and
then put the clothes in I never did that
until I would get jammed up I would put
I find out in the morning as a kid I
pulled all my clothes in like my jeans
are like whatever and then just dump the
stuff right on air and sometimes it
don't always come out like that stains
it and you come out with soap stains on
your thing looking like it look like you
[__] peed a little bit when you went
to the bathroom
I'm trying to score okay let's talk
about Trade coffee shout out to the
trade let's talk about that lukewarm
crap that you get over there at the
drive through what are you doing
what you want is you want trade coffee
you want a delicious cup of coffee
they're matching algorithm will tell you
exactly what you like and what you want
they got over 450 coffees to choose from
what are we doing here yeah you'll
definitely find your favorite uh we've
been using it for the past uh couple of
weeks here delicious it's fantastic
air out the door two seconds flat like I
said it's delicious yeah uh with free
shipping customize customizable plans
anytime cancellations it's easier than I
ever discover incredible coffee uh if
you don't if you didn't think this could
get any better your coffee is always
shipped within 48 Hours of being roasted
holy that's formed the table or
something that's real quick that's
better than Amazon Prime
uh get ready for the best coffee uh of
your life with trade go to
drinktrade.com
ayg to receive a free bag of coffee with
any subscription that's a free bag of
coffee with any trade subscription at
ringtrade.com
ayg or clicking a link in the show notes
your next cup of coffee is on us check
it out this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp let me tell you something
what's that signed up yeah I've been
Screwballs I've been driving myself nuts
you've been driving me nuts I've been
telling you for two three years I've
been driving myself nuts I couldn't find
a therapist around here that I liked it
was this it was that it was it was just
a nightmare man better help you boom
you're talking to a license therapist
two seconds you could do text you could
do video you could do just over the
phone and here's the turkey you don't
have a specialist in your area they got
you covered man that helps all right
listen I'm crazy do yourself a favor
talk it out with Better Health I'm crazy
listen to me
and what are you looking at whether
you're dealing with choices about your
career relationship or family anything
it doesn't gonna be that deep it's
better helps online therapy helps you
stay connected uh to what you really
want out of life uh getting started is
easy just fill out quick questionnaire
get matched with a licensed therapist
switch therapist at any time no digital
charge no questions asked uh getting
into therapy helps you move forward and
make decisions with confidence baby it's
a big tool I've always said it uh let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com garbage today and
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com garbage betterhelp.com garbage
do it do it back to the show I don't
trust those little pods either oh I love
them people throw them right in there
you're supposed to put them in the in
the detergent bin oh I don't do I throw
them right in there throw them right in
there oh you're supposed to throw them
right in yeah yeah I don't think they'll
go through the detergent thing the
water's got to dissolve that they take
two treatments to dissolve I can see why
kids eat them they do they do have like
a hairy bow type vibe to them you want
to pop it because it's not poppable
you'll want a pot you wanna yeah yeah I
get jammed up with the ones in the
dishwasher I can't touch them too much
no did you ever turn anything pink I was
so I always thought it was gonna be a
myth no my wife just did it recently
there was real yeah there was something
I think it was like a rag and I think it
was partly my fault I was supposed to
it's got to be brand new yeah I think it
was a brand new sweater or brand new
sweatshirt or something like that and I
had something got linked up in it that
I'm pretty sure was my fault and I was
like oh yeah that's good and she just
went through it like didn't double check
went through it and something came out
pink it was like jeans or something
something I jammed up Pink jeans yeah
I'm wearing them to dinner today like
getting sauntering around
um but gang we got a goddamn Family
episode let's get to some [__]
patreon yes we do
um all right let's see here uh this
one's from Mr and Mrs weidenbush like it
shout out to the widen bushes
is it garbage to wash your family's dog
in the above ground pool
that blew me away when when Bert
explained the shout the pool shower to
us I I understand jumping in the pool
and taking a quick dinner but you're
using soap in the pool is insane that
seems like it ruins the pool for
everybody out dude and also washing a
dog is the dirtiest like it's that dog
soap I can smell that we do it we do it
in the in the bathroom and like we'll do
it before we clean like all right we got
to clean the bathroom or whatever like
let's clean him because it's like once
you do that it's [__] but you might
see him popping around he's yeah the dog
is he said he's dog is floating around
um
[__] investment
um The Vig it's dudes it's like it's
change it's not like someone else is
bathing in your it's a [__] it's
another species the [__] [__] in the
hair the hairs everywhere a butthole oh
God it's horrible so to do that in your
pool then mix soap and [__] in there
like what do you gotta skim it after
that right there's got it looks like the
[__] Exxon Valdez on top of that
water then
yeah it's a tough look who the [__]
wants dude if you invited me over your
house and I get there for like a nice
Fun in the Sun but we got two three land
sharks in you you got a hot dog hey
Kippy won't you hopping and taking dip
and I look and it looks like a goddamn
grease trap in there or you get in there
and they say yeah we just washed the dog
I would [__] burn your house down
that is for sure if you [__] set me
up to jump in a dog bath pool no not
happening I think it ruined the pool for
everybody even like what Bert does that
like I wouldn't want to I then it makes
it seem then you're you're swimming in
their bath water
especially an above ground pool those
filters ain't the best that's a that's a
step above a pond yeah
um Trish yeah very very Trish uh let's
see his renewment are you garbage you
have any vehicles on the street or the
driveway that lives in a car cover this
can go either good or bad there's no
real middle ground
car cover man there's never
there's never a good nine times out of
ten it's a T-top Thunderbird with a
blown transmission yeah there's an
narrow working vehicle underneath or
it's a [__] super high-end Porsche
like which is the gun no one's putting
if it's a super high-end Porsche it's in
a garage under one of those things yeah
it's not out next to the garage on the
grass
behind the shed yeah again that is
[__] B City that's hornetville right
there that's how you get jammed up you
roll out there on a nice May afternoon
I'm gonna take the car out and you whip
that thing off and all of a sudden dude
you're getting dive bombed yeah no
a tough look I've never seen that with a
working vehicle does that say that's
what saves the paint right from the Sun
and the rain I guess but like and from
like sap from trees is big I gotcha but
is that like
nah dude I parked under a tree [__]
last week my car Jesus Christ looks like
it was that burning man dude it's
[__]
it's covered in just [__] bird [__]
dust pollen bees coming out of this
country ass down
bees pollen uh yeah it's [__] the
trees I was under there for [__] four
or five days I'm in the garage it looks
like it's a [__] disabled vehicle
looks like I'm waiting on [__] Triple
A to come pick me up yeah that's bad at
least get it running and she gotta show
the neighbors that it runs too otherwise
cause they're talking about you why do
people
I guess if you're a car guy but why do
you keep cars that don't work
that just happens right yes I think it's
that's like when an aunt or Uncle moves
in it just kind of happened I think it
yes it's a short-term thing oh I'll get
it going and I think guys
you I think there's really I look at it
as the same way [__] was never finished
at my house is because my stepdad was a
construction worker and it's like the
roofer always has the worst roof in the
neighborhood the landscaper has the
worst yard
because they do it all the time they
come back it's like you you never have
the time to do it yourself so you think
you have you think you're gonna wake up
Sunday morning I'm gonna go Tinker have
a beer with the boys that [__] never
comes before wish if it does sure but
it's like that's like the one percent I
wonder if guys still do that the guys
still get together and like meet up and
work on cars and stuff like they get
their car guys yeah I think like men
real men yeah that's a real man you know
what I always wanted to do did you
change your oil if you had to
yeah I could I could well I no I don't
know how to without a YouTube tutorial
no no YouTube tutorial I'll be all over
that thing like [__] take that engine
right out
I got the gun with the [__] the drill
with the hose on it uh yeah no I
couldn't I feel like I'm I mean like I
think actual
that's like pretty dummy proof If you
know what you're doing you know what I
mean it's made for the common person to
be able to do it I just don't know where
the oil you're not like redoing the
calibrator
the carburetor and I recalibrating the
carburetor
I drive a Kia there's no carburetor in a
Kia catalytic converter there's no more
not anymore they took them [__] oh
man dudes [__] my neighborhood all
you got to talk about it I keep
forgetting we got to talk about a hard
feelings or two or three things about it
my neighborhood's going this [__] really
quick no kidding my plates got stolen
which we say has been documented sure
um and then they just put my wife just
sent me a picture from the Facebook
group it was a [__] Corolla it's like
a nicer sedan but not like a luxury car
but like a nicer looks good sedan
[__] propped up on milk crates
[__] all four tires gone man gone
overnight these are powerful milk crates
I don't know they were collapsing uh
they were really [__] must have been
chocolate also do you remember the milk
crate challenge I went down a rabbit oh
dude I saw one the other day I was
[__] dying that's the tall skinny
girl that goes up that's making a
Resurgence man oh it is no the videos
are just coming back but they're the old
vit dude that should have been a goddamn
TV show that should be on Netflix that
was the height of the pandemic
[__] just going back outside
for the first time and start eating [__]
dude oh my God it was genius though oh
it was proper genius so funny so that
should be in stadiums dude why don't
that you let's pitch that TV show that
should be the show no kidding that
should be in the Olympics dude you do
that at Madison Square Garden people
would do just get like a tough mudder
type thing get a bunch of contestants
dude you get some older guy with a
couple of drinks in them trying to show
off in front of the young kids then they
get to like the second or third highest
one and then it's over and I assume
people had to be getting severely yeah
people were getting [__] up dude you
fall hit your spleen on one of those
things nah people are getting real
jammed up real bad yo like serious yeah
yeah like when they folded half the
other way or the sideways
man why is it funny when people get hurt
I mean that was jackass that was so much
[__] it's so what is in the human
condition that you love seeing a
[__] eat [__]
I don't know it's great I got a little
Joy at you saying the neighborhood was
going bad I know you did I don't know
why uh uh yeah just and there was
something else that we have to wait for
hard feelings uh they're taking these
conversions left and right I know the
[__] are they doing with them then I'm
getting I drive a k I'm getting things
left and right if I gotta take it in to
get the [__] security system because
they're stealing so many of them I just
want to [__] turn that thing in
because now there's one bad street not
bad where's your lease up on that thing
I think I have another year another year
that doesn't make sense I think you got
it in 2020. I got it in March of
2021. did you okay so I think I have
until next March so yeah whatever hey
Jamie up if you try to get rid of that
thing 10 months or whatever but there's
so there's a I could steal it for you
buy buy the there's a park in my
neighbor by the park there's one street
that's
there's no houses on it just bat bats up
to the back of a church and a pot like a
school and then there's no houses it's
the park on one side then a school and a
church so
they there's no one there at night
so the cars that are on that block
that's just where they're going like I
have at least eight minutes to do
whatever I need to you know no one's
gonna come out or walk at home or
whatever
uh so I can't even Park on that thing
anymore because I'm afraid it's a
[__] kid are gonna they're gonna
steal it so now it's tougher to park let
me ask you this what you know this is
off the Record hypothetically would that
be the worst case scenario what the fool
you trying to jam me up if that thing
this how long do you know listen we're
dirt bags they're sitting here talking
to three year old talk about this on air
right now no I'm just saying if by
chance well you put it out there I'm Jim
my car gets stolen I'm gonna be jammed
up this [__] guy
been setting you up all week no you're
probably gonna steal my car then [__]
call the fuzz and pit me off
we have a couple flatbreads at the scene
yeah he's the king of flappers it's a Mr
Neptune trophy
[Laughter]
body surfing champ like in 2002 bottle
of Rogaine at the crime scene Mr
adaptive trophy is definitely a guy
flexing holding a fish yeah
but I tried it in the other hand yeah
he's got us he's got a [__]
cheesesteak from NLP
um [__] what did we get to oh oh to go
back without changing that what I always
wanted as a kid coming from a family of
construction workers was the The Hangout
of uh in Home Improvement how their hang
was the hardware store they go in they
and also the garage yeah buddy go in
they get a coffee they hang out they
shoot this [__] what are you working on
I got this that's all I wanted how was
he what the hell was he pulling down on
that show he did all right Tim the
toolman Taylor wait in the Tim the
toolman Taylor or Tim Allen no I know
Tim Allen was Caked Up Tim the Tool Man
Taylor was doing pretty good for a local
celebrity oh yeah Benford
I guess so that was a [__] because he
had the nice girl garage with all the
tools yeah he was a he was a local
celebrity when that was money what do
you think Tim Allen made per rep of Home
Improvement eight hundred thousand
dollars stop
um does it say what season
just is what it says
at the height I'm gonna say
I want to say 1.2 but I feel like when
friends started making a million that
was the big that was the biggest thing I
gotta go 800.
um
but I don't know is this as like a fee
or he was probably co-creator like they
were just million dollars he created I
know I'm saying they were like Millions
based on his stand-up I know that's all
I'm saying I don't know if that's
factored into what he was making as a
Creator as a producer this this is a
talent fee Maybe
just guess 750. you had it on the nose
dude 1.25 million get the [__] out of
here
23 episodes of season two cake though
man
cool remember when we did them as
stickers treat
yeah yeah man that Tanked
I was Tim Allen he was Al Borland and we
had to go out into a minute of Comedy
for a Halloween show it was a famous uh
I think they still do it I think Norman
started it was Norman and Matt Ruby show
yeah they did sticker treat where you go
out as famous comedians or actors or
whatever and do a minute and we went out
as Tim and Al Borland yeah swinging to
miss not well received that was pretty
good mixed review it was pretty good
an episode though shout out to him yikes
oh God damn holy [__] uh all right
golden age of television
yeah that's when [__] TV money was
[__]
nice uh all right this one's from Brad
ten dollar homie never had one red is it
trash if you and your mom have matching
tram stance I'm a dude by the way
uh yeah what I mean trans amps for a guy
were cool in some circles for like an
hour like I think people were like yeah
this is cool because more dudes
have them than should on the back in the
in the lower back
the [__] Stamp didn't get its name
until a bunch of who has got it yeah so
it was just I'm not saying a cool place
but it was a place for a tattoo right
and I think they were like I think
people are like oh cool you can get a
lower back tattoo and then like
a thousand guys did it and 15 million
girls did it and it was like oh well I'm
jammed up here uh my a mom getting a
tattoo if your mom wanted to get a
tattoo
depends what it was
huh
Popeye
uh
uh no no I would I mean I would let her
get her if she would get like two paws
like that she want to get her mom's
initials or something sure yeah yeah
that I mean I she wouldn't you know what
I mean if I can describe
um
but yeah no that would be tough if my
mom came home was like ah hey I just got
some fresh ink couple teardrops all
right [__] I put her in a home right
away
you can't be trusted this bro lost their
mind
your honor she got it that too
his case is closed
um yeah that's not good you're only your
mom having mat I mean
ah I don't know I never had that
relationship with my mom where we'd get
matching tattoos you know we were never
some some I think some kids grow up like
friends with their mom yeah I didn't
have that no like dudes grow up where
they're like oh yeah it's like a very
open relationship about um
smoking drinking sex all that kind of
stuff it's like their roommates kind of
a lot of time when the dad's not around
I feel that's the case sure and she like
works nights as a nurse at the [__]
at the hospital it's like they're he's
like independent he gets independent
quick yeah and then they become like
boys yeah now Patty was a tyrant we're
cool now but at the time bad news she
ran with an iron fist
yeah my mom was always I I I I I knew
how to toe the line to not get in too
much I'd watch my brother blow the
[__] doors off the place I was like
as long as I mine my p's and q's a
little bit more than he did I was flying
under the radar yeah I had a pretty good
system it's mostly lion
you were at Sleep Away School wherever
the [__] you were oh yeah which I was
trying to pin down your parents are
learning people correct your father's a
smart man Professor author your mother
worked credible financial institutions
correct what was the angle of sending
you
like was the school you went to a good
school yeah sleep away school what do
you want to live with him when he was a
teenager I want to ship him away now
most days you're imagine him [__] as a
teenager dude did you have that hair
back then too yeah and I love scar oh
how dude I think about how much he
sucked
surprised you weren't in the French
Foreign Legion he yelling at his mom
you're not my mom you're like what the
[__] dude yeah but what was the so that
was a good school yeah
yeah for what like for literature or
donors yeah it wasn't an athletic school
no they played quidditch
didn't you
played a lot of Ultimate Frisbee dude
you definitely had a lot of horse people
at that school kids that thought they
were horses running around
that's every school what'd you say there
were some kids doing some heroin little
horse yeah sure of course
um yeah man I was thinking about that
the other day for some reason like what
was the like the the path they wanted
you to was it like disciplinary of like
I can't take this anymore or they're
like this you were drinking and not
talking total opposite it was that the
school system in Lincolnton North
Carolina Tiny Town right I get that dog
[__] full of math no good I didn't go to
middle school and they were just like uh
I was backpacking through Europe we
gotta get this kid an opportunity so
they're like we're gonna take all of the
uh all the money they had saved up for
my college and we're gonna gamble it on
high school thinking that I get a full
ride I'm a bad [__] business what
were they addicted to scratchers who
does that what did they think you were
gonna get a full ride in I don't know
attitude basket weaving being the most
creative little guy
oh look at you now yeah
it works out
that's I mean that's crazy I would never
forgive my parents if they ship me away
like that I wanted to go
um I wanted to do a prep year
I wanted to go to Mercersburg Academy
after college After High School After
High School because I had a couple
options
go home with something to roll on I had
one or two options playing around I
could go play I could become a drug
addict here or I can become a drag there
I could go play division three football
at the couple schools
um or if you prep the year they had a
program there where I would I would con
I would get to continue to play high
school football in my prep here and play
other prep schools
I think it was nice give Mercersburg
Academy a a goog I think it's a good
school I didn't get in academically it
has to be at least be okay then yeah
but I thought I'd be like a super senior
yeah because you're even hold on to the
Glory Days then yeah you didn't want to
give me one more year you're not get me
out of here where the [__] where the
cigs are flowing like this I just
happened to Capistrano you're nuts can't
be down in a temple where no one's
looking yeah get me to North Philly
where I'm not a problem let's go what
are we talking about you want to go back
I can still play high school I don't
seemed nice yeah at 72 000 a year it
better be damn yeah your mom didn't even
send the application out she just told
you you didn't get it
Fat Bastard not Mortgage in the house or
this [__] idiot 72 jihads yeah for
you to go bully some sophomore
what's up loser I'm so cool I'm back in
high school what's up I'm 19.
[Laughter]
ah man it ain't that far off on the
island yo no I know but it's so funny I
used to think about that any word even
over and you're like how can I really
squeeze every list drop a cool out of
here I mean well I just kind of started
to be good at it
so I figured one more year those kids in
college were tough they beat the [__]
out of me yeah you should have learned
your [__] teach A Life Lesson be
beaten up you're gonna avoid what you're
gonna be [__] hanged we had a bunch
of kids that were supposed to be in
division one but didn't didn't make the
grades and they were down there [__]
it was like [__] fighting the
Avengers every [__] the Gladiators
[__] some guy running me over yeah
holy [__] man that's what 72 Grand I
thought my whole life would have been
different if I could have gotten there
you're you they're living with me on
campus
who's that guy who's got his parents in
his dorm
we're a tight-knit group someone's got
to do my laundry
oh he came in licking his lips that
ain't good yeah here honzi
um it's so funny because you can only
see his tail it's like a little
telescope 72 Grand the year a periscope
I wanted to go to that's a good school I
wanted to go to the agricultural school
I thought that would have been so cool
in Roxboro was that off Henry Ave
[__] major in cow [__]
I'm scared yeah it was it you'd be like
you become a farmer or whatever it was
like teaches you Agriculture and what
were you gonna Farm what where are we
you should start growing my own weed
dude uh
uh no I don't know it just was different
and high school [__] was mad corny I
wanted to do something cool agriculture
I mean that was corny yeah where were
you gonna Farm I don't think it was Farm
I think it was like I mean T-Bone looked
that up like Philadelphia agricultural
School Roxboro he wanted a genetically
engineer thicker milk
give me something give me a bigger
forehead what's more than whole
this guy invented double hole
did you hear about this [__] loser in
village
chocolate half and a half uh
yeah I don't know why I wanted to do it
though so bad I always wanted to go to
uh this isn't this isn't school I just
didn't want to be in school
if I could catch heaters and ride a
couple of Steves
the Walter Biddle Saul High School Of
Agricultural Sciences what town is it in
uh
uh Philadelphia yeah it's gotta be it
you're going to go to an agriculture
School in the city of Philadelphia
how to grow cocoa plant
turning eighth into a [__] half what
are we talking yeah we're down there
growing long Hots on a roof
no my oh my two of my friends had a
little bit of geese a little bit a
little bit a little bit of green some
ghee when I was a kid oh gee old school
a little bit again
shout out to it
um but they uh when I started hanging
out with them they had been going to
this Camp called Camp Tecumseh in New
Hampshire which sounded like [__]
heaven and I want it to go and Patty had
this guy come in and Pitch it and he was
in there for like an hour she had the
cake out and the coffee and I think it
was like 15 grand or something yeah nope
get out see if I can threw the guy out
Midway through his pound cake I remember
I wanted to play paintball in the
Poconos for like 150 bucks for a weekend
and my mom was like get the [__] out of
here yeah laundry to do
my scrubs ain't gonna clean themselves
I'll get your fat ass in the laundry
room cleaning blood out of her ER scrubs
Jesus Christ
I wanted it was called Skirmish in the
Poconos and it was [__] I wanted to
it was like a war game you would go for
like a weekend it was like D-Day or
something or nah it was like based on a
war I wanted nothing more to go she was
like no [__] way
she thought someone was gonna try to
molest me I said I got a paintball gun
I'll shoot his weiner up what are you
talking oh you think I'm gonna let some
dude grab my junk
good luck finding it it's cold out there
in the woods
Mercersburg Academy so that never would
have happened she probably didn't send
it in you got to figure if it's 70 grand
now what was it in 1994. no but that
those kind of things exploded now like
those private school [__] that [__] that
[__] crazy exploded it was obviously
expensive in the 90s nice you live there
it's not it didn't scale up
[__] dogs all over the place
get a Honda put a GoPro on them
[Laughter]
he's a good boy uh all right let's see
here this one's from dirt ten dollar
homie uh it's like Madonna Just dirt 10
homie never have one red how about jeans
and a kayak
that's not uh that ain't a good
I'm petrified of kayaks really like
canoes yeah kayaks yeah No never they
spin
they spin and you can't get out no
that's canoe
no no that's that's a river kayak or
something what's ocean kayaks are like
exposed there are two types of kayaks
yeah there's the open top kayak the big
plastic John and then there's the ones
that you sit in yeah like with your
white water rafting type [__]
I mean never I have to I wouldn't fit
have NASA make you one they do they do
they do that on the East River
they have a little canaya kayaking
kenayaking kayaking classes yeah I mean
I went kayaking in the Hudson
oh no what if you spin now you're not
closed in I'd be more worried about
finding a body like the opening of a Law
and Order episode dude I've been
crushing Law and Order the pit since
[__] 18's been going crushing it
really good program are you watching
that peacock
uh are you getting the old reps today
he's watching TNT and rolling the dice
yeah no it's open you get a Briscoe it's
uh oh there you go heavy briskies uh
they give it um it's on like pop or we
TV city was wide open back then think
about that Brisco running around
straightening everybody the [__] out who
is his boy Mr Big from um
sex and the Sex in the City uh Lenny
Briscoe and ah it's gonna drive me crazy
God damn it
what's his name Christopher North no
North yeah
just get in here hansy
how's your problem
Christopher North Law and Order his name
was Mike Logan Logan and Briscoe get on
it that was a team yeah they'd get you
eventually
Brisco nothing gets past him what are
you know in Punk
plus he was on the sauce it was off the
sauce sure but he had you know he did go
back on at that one episode yeah walked
into that bar he had to put on he had to
like do something with his morals
something and he was like you know what
yeah who tree Shooters sure I was no
mixed drink I'll tell you that ah give
me four four cuddies and a tall boy
that's how you go
uh Gone Baby Gone yeah [__] love the
cheddar
cheese cheese
[Laughter]
I [__] love that movie yeah that's
good uh all right let's see here boys
um we've talked about this kind of Matt
this is from Matt uh is it garbage to go
bowling while on vacation
the garbage to go bowling while on
vacation
I think bowling is trashy in general
it's not I'm not saying it's not fun
bowling's a good time I think it's fun
for two throws and then I'm out bowling
on vacation is a no-go yeah horrible
activity all right so great I do love
there was nothing better than getting
you know going there having about 15 18
beers playing half a game and you know I
like the idea of bowling I hate to say
this I like the idea of it yeah but
after [__] four four rounds you're
like all right I don't give a [__] and
on vacation you should be having
something better to do although you
can't but what if it's like lights up
bowling and you got the kids and I like
that kind of stuff I like going to the
movies on vacation you shouldn't do
anything on vacation that you can do at
home yeah unless it's a very he says
that me and Kippy just now yeah unless
it's a very unique experience so you
don't go to dinner on vacation yeah but
you don't go to bed on vacation I don't
go to McDonald's on vacation yeah you're
going that's crazy
I go to McDonald's for vacation
it's been a weekend there Six Days Seven
Nights
how come there's no McDonald's Cruise
you would think they would have tapped
into that by now that thing would sink
[Laughter]
bunch of [__] heifers could you
imagine that if it was a McDonald's
Cruise six days
there's not enough Rascals in the world
man if they had if they had a Big Mac
buffet or something if no if they had a
McDonald's Buffet on a cruise where you
can just go ham
McDonald's breakfast buffet you build
your own sandwiches build your own big
breakfast
that'd be pretty good I bet you a lot
more people than you think would sign up
for that
I don't know how they do the booze
though
how to get around the booze is there a
McDonald's Cruise there all right
there's a Bayville McDonald's cruise
night in Atlantic City where guys show
up with their cars at the McDonald's and
they go for a cruise I think that's
about as close you're gonna get yeah
that stinks yeah
they do have that crazy uh uh one on
Long Islands in a mansion like you call
it the White House or something
it's like a [__] Mickey D's in a
mansion out there honey if you had a
McDonald's Cruise have the whole thing
look like a playland you know like
they're but
who's that really catering because you
wouldn't go you would want to go but you
wouldn't go are there people who are
that I'm not saying obviously there's
people that eat it three times a day
every day whatever the [__] I'm not
saying it's not consumed it's obviously
consumed but like I don't think people
make that their lives like who would
want to be like
and you could get a thousand people on
that thing do a little boat
yeah I don't know I don't I mean you do
like the idea of a McDonald's Buffet
though right no I don't eat McDonald's
that much all right you have a love
affair with like you're obsessed with it
I wouldn't say I'm obsessed I enjoy the
product you came up with a McDonald's
cruise and what do you mean that's what
I did trademarked h12 bam Bender
so if anybody with the ray Crocker
organization wants to play ball give me
a call All Rights Reserved yeah uh this
one Jamie up this one's just funny this
is from Kyle 50 Bozo here never have one
red is it garbage man is it garbage to
lie about your patreon tier
my man I respect it yeah fake it till
you make it pushing people in line get
out of the way
uh all right this one's from Sergeant
hangs low uh is it garbage have your
braces repoed because your dad didn't
make the payments because he couldn't
shake the lotto cards did they do that
I guess my mom always made it feel like
we were behind on orthodontist payments
and they always they were never warm and
friendly when I went in there and I had
them on for about three years because I
was so bad with them
I didn't get them taken off until my
senior year I was so [__] bad with my
brother I saw you wanted an extra year a
high school's [__] flaunted Chompers
around sure before they turned into
those little baked bean messages I'm
sure
short [__] Meth mouth over here yeah
I was terrible with braces I hated the
whole thing of it yeah
um I never had them I had like I've said
I had the appliance like the medieval
[__] jaw expander palette expander
expansion or whatever that [__]
ironic for a guy who only eats chicken
tenders yeah still woofing them down huh
what pallet extender oh I eat more stuff
than you do I just really like chicken
if you don't like seafood that's true I
don't eat one third of food yeah this
guy that is always say this you throw
shade at me I'll try anything you don't
like seafood no it's just I find it to
be repulsive really but they told him
that hippie dippy school yeah no kidding
don't eat Crustaceans man I was
vegetarian all four years
oh yeah you're what vegetarian all four
years High School wow so you really
sucked like just as a person you sucked
listening to ska veggie probably listen
I love vegetarianism but you were
probably really opinionated about it
Opposite sure no it's the it
the two most uncool people are vegans
and vegetarians won't shut up about it
and sober people who won't shut up about
it so it's like my goal in life was to
be like a chill vegetarian and then now
like the coolest sober guy you know I'll
give you that you're in a very normal
sober dude oh yeah yeah you want to know
you're sober now you go to a bar you
don't make a big deal about it no I'm
not a [__] yeah
we're eating a lot of tofu were you a
big tofu guy Huns tons of stuff that
looks like Feta no yeah
you fed him what are we doing here
tofu's all right man you go to a good uh
Korean barbecue joint they give you that
with a little bit of that bean sauce on
it
seitan is fire too nah I can't do that
stuff I remember when I first got I
would call eating an insole of a shoe
what is it it's some something made out
of soy
kick rocks with that what are we talking
about give me a [__] Rotel and let's
call it a goddamn day oh dude this
description is awful seitan is a mildly
flavored high protein meat substitute
made of wheat gluten sounds like a
festival ban he's opening up for him
seitan all right
brutal
uh
you put enough soy sauce and [__] on
that stuff it's still good oh yeah damn
a little broccoli whatever it's all
right a little fried tofu and a Caesar
wrap come on yeah I actually now that uh
and you have the balls to talk about my
palate I went to a vegetarian dinner
party one time I think in my late 20s
early 30s imagine the bad jokes you made
um it was tough it was up it was a it
was a vegetarian potluck at somebody's
parents house why would you even do that
I don't know my friends were going
yeah eat my plug
I know we had they somebody made seitan
and had to pretend oh this is great the
[__] out of here get me on that
McDonald's Cruise
All Aboard
later uh all right this one's from Dan
it's garbage if your in-laws bread
chicken with crushed up Doritos and call
it Mexican chicken
listen I like a heavy crust on
a piece of meat I do
that wouldn't be bad that's probably
pretty good and you know what you're
ready for frying I thought they were
feeding Doritos to the chickens to try
and Infuse them with flavor working on
the inside out baby that's all right I
would respect that
see these porks here give them nothing
but Funyuns
no I respect I mean uh uh well you know
it's something that was that was very
popular in the 80s and 90s Patty didn't
[__] with it
maybe every once in a while she'd put it
on top of a casserole what would be Corn
Flakes
huh I've had I've had chicken fingers
that were that were done in corn flakes
it's like panko style yeah they were
awesome what the [__] course
delicious like breakfast and dinner at
the same time yeah not bad uh yeah I
would do I'd do like a heavy heavy so
that would be great because I figured
that would [__] really really harden
up you know doesn't do a nice bark you
know it doesn't do it that well and I
hate to say it but Taco Bell they're
Doritos
collabs just it ain't it's yeah no good
no bueno they're like soggy and they
don't really taste everything you know
Taco Bell is SOG I've never had like a
decent I I understand
um this is Blasphemous to both of you
I'm just giving you my personal
experience I raised up on you
um back in the 90s forget about it now
it's like dude everything it's like it's
like slop at least at Burger King
Wendy's Chick-fil-A Mickey D's the
presentation is all right sure it's not
bad it's not bad it's not fantastic it's
not bad but the presentation there looks
like you know the guy [__] a rapper
and gave it to me it stinks
[__] over here eating bean paste or
something no way dude I will go to bat
for the quesarito every day of the god
the grill it's good it's the best fast
food on Earth and it looks like [__] the
Pres I'm not saying it's not good and
you don't like it the present it is the
worst in presentation out of all of it
you got it give you a hand job every
time you order a goddamn you gotta go
there for sure at Taco Bell you gotta
order it there and sit and eat it there
you're eating your memories because if
you open that up it looks horrible oh
that's a good name for my Memoir eating
my memories
the new book by H Foley eating my
memories available on gel's now gang
in the cereal aisle yeah that's all
right all right uh let's do one more and
we gotta rip it up there again this
one's remote ten dollar homie
um
is it garbage if your city is known for
three things and he doesn't ask the city
so let's see if we can guess it okay all
right is it garbage if your city is
known for three things and they are it
is the Slurpee capital of the world
murder capital of the world and home of
Crown Royal
all three pretty good things
Slurpee I guess
does he doesn't say at the bottom yeah I
mean we're gonna have to Google this
yeah don't do it give it a Google Toby
wants to guess okay
I'm gonna go Midwest somewhere but
what's the murder cap of the world is
that per capita is that numbers you
never know I think I have it
I feel like if it was murder you gotta
go chicago-ish maybe Detroit but if it
was Chicago Toby would know at least on
a Slurpee Capital I'm gonna say
St Louis I was kind of leaning that
um I don't know why I'm going Midwest
with Slurpee but I'm going Midwest
uh Crown Royal is that
uh I mean it's not the Northeast it's
not manufactured there I think just it's
very popular Crown Royal is very popular
this is the home of Crown Royal the home
of Crown Royal
huh uh I think St Louis I was going I
was lean in Midwest
but we were in St Louis I don't remember
nobody gave me a bottle of car no one
shot me gave me a bottle of crown they
do call it murder City okay
I think it's one it's either St Louis or
one of those cities like that that we're
just not thinking yeah yeah yeah yeah
one of those Midwest cities that we're
missing well I think might get my
initial gut reaction was something it's
definitely not West Coast and it's
definitely not Northeast I don't think
it's the South what kind of liquor is
Crown Royal it's a dark brown whiskey
whiskey it's whiskey hmm
is it Canadian I think it's I thought it
was Canadian or is that Canadian Club
Vos Canadian nobody gets murdered in
Canada
not that it'll be the murder capital
but it could it's the Slurpee Capital
World Slurpees is American [__]
institution adding Canadians yeah they
call them squuzzies or something give me
a squeegee I'm gonna say uh
St Louis or Phoenix
okay yeah I'm going Midway I don't know
but I'm going Midwest St Louis sounds
right to me give it
I guess you just do home of the Slurpee
Slurpee capital of the world see what
comes up or just do where Crown Royals
made that's what I did no if it is the
yeah
it's saying Canada what the Slurpee yeah
whoa no no the Crown Royal I yeah that's
what I'm saying I think it might be
manufactured there but it might be
what city drinks the most Crown Royal
give that again Winnipeg whoa it's
[__] Canadian Jesus
as it turns out
Winnipeg drinks the most Slurpees each
year of any City not just in Canada but
the entire world what the [__] and
you're saying Crown Royals made in
Canada yeah
and they got that many murders up there
I guess
murders in Winnipeg well Tijuana is the
Myrtle Capital world
but still
Jesus Christ it might be the murder
capital of Canada we had two guys
scrapping one of them hit their head one
of them died of a heart attack
Jesus he was sick for a long time though
so it could have been the gout that got
him holy [__] man you learned something
new every day here on the program I'll
tell you this right now I do love Canada
I love the Canadian homies and bosses I
ain't never having another goddamn
Slurpee in my I'm an icy man from here
really can't be given wait it's not
Canadian they just drink them all right
cheers I'll touch you with a Slurpee
next yeah yeah okay shout out to Canada
I'm supporting local homegrown I like it
some places got to be the Slurpee
Capital well I'm glad that it's a
Winnipeg I'm glad that it's just your
address yeah we Google it
all right let's quit screwing around
gang we love you to death yep and we'll
see you next time peace peace